now one of three people accused in a  string of deadly crimes stretching from  texas to arizona to here in nevada  expected in court today henderson police  say two men and a woman  shot at dozens of people on thanksgiving  day killing a man at a 7-eleven near  downtown henderson  22 year old kevin mendiola junior was  killed detectives identified the  suspects as  shawn and christopher mcdonnell and  kaylee lewis a police report claims all  three were in a car  driving around henderson randomly  shooting at people in cars  after mendiola was killed investigators  say the three  stole a car and then drove to arizona  and there they were arrested after an  officer-involved shooting we'll let you  know how the court hearing goes today